how's the little one doing but we're
we're very excited look we wouldn't do
this four times if we didn't love it
Ryan Reynolds shares a family update
after Blake Lively welcomes baby number
four have you figured it all out yet the
parenting thing you could ask me about
90 years and I'm gonna say you know and
Ryan calls out the media for announcing
the birth of their little one before he
and his wife did it's completely
ridiculous earlier this week Ryan
stopped by cnbc's power lunch and shared
an update on life with Blake as a family
of six the lovebirds who tied the knot
in 2012 are parents to three daughters
eight-year-old James six-year-old Inez
and three-year-old Betty four under 10
years old how excited excited are you
and Blake I'm we're very excited you
know uh we'd have to be you know you'd
have to be a to do this four times
if you didn't like it
um yeah yeah it's gonna be a nuts uh but
we're very excited and news of baby
number Four's arrival broke earlier this
month though no details have been shared
how's Blake doing is she sleeping
everybody's doing great and I
everybody's actually doing fantastic I
mean we haven't figured it out by now I
think we'd be in deep deep trouble but
uh but yeah it's a zoo over here I mean
this is like a this is my office here
this is where I'll probably actually to
be honest I'll probably spend the rest
of my life in here as for the gender
Ryan stayed tight-lipped boy or girl
I ain't telling this ain't a birth
announcement yeah the couple never
actually made a birth announcement but
fans and the media were tipped off when
Blake shared this pick on Super Bowl
Sunday without a visible baby bump we
didn't make the birth announcement it
was we just posted a photo and the the
media sort of did what it does after
that the couple revealed they were
expecting a fourth bundle of joy back in
September when Blake showed off her
growing baby bump at the 10th Annual
Forbes power Women's Summit in New York
City
foreign
[Applause]
after giving birth to their first child
the actors opened up to ET about how
much they love their new roles as Mom
and Dad do you now that your mom do you
take like looks and keep them and maybe
you want to pass them on oh now I've
done it always like since I've been 16
I'm like my child will love this piece
from Forever 21 one day that's just like
falling apart that they're never gonna
want it you look at this little face you
think God I'm only gonna know this
person for you know hopefully 50 55
years you know it doesn't suddenly it
doesn't seem like a long time fast
forward to 2021 Ryan pushed pause on his
career to soak in time with his kids
it's really about getting some quality
time with my kids before they're uh
before their you know teenagers who
loathe me and the Deadpool star told us
he's glad he did I took a year off I
just love being home with my family and
you know taking the kids to school I
have so many other aspects of my life
that keep me busy and it seems like
you've been busy with a friend
friendship bracelets too oh yeah my
daughters love to love to make Daddy
bracelets yeah probably tracking devices
actually now that I think about truth be
telling them
[Music]